AMD released its rx 400 series graphics
cards last year while they couldn't
match the performance of Nvidia's high
intensities GPUs they arguably offered
more bang for the buck aim these new 500
series video cards are built on the same
underlying Polaris mark architecture but
have been refined through a more mature
14 nanometer manufacturing process that
allows them to run a bit faster the RX
580 leads the charge of performance this
time around and supplants aim these are
X 480 alongside that the company sent us
is rx 570 to test this card replaces
AMD's rx 470 like the 400 series before
the RX 580 and 570 still target
mainstream users with starting prices at
199 and 169 AMD asserts that the RX 580
is competitive with Nvidia's $300 gtx
1060 and that an overclocked rx 570 is
on par with the companies $240 our X 480
well test those claims in our review
spec ones the RX 580 is very similar to
the RX 480 before it it features the
same amount of stream processors compute
units and video ram its biggest
advantage is that it offers faster core
and boost clocks with its 13 40
megahertz boost frequency the RX 580 is
74 megahertz faster than the RX 4 80
this makes the RX 580 a 6.17 teraflop
GPU on the downside with a 185 watt TDP
the RX 580 consumes up to 35 more watts
in the RX 4 80 this makes it slightly
more power hungry than nvidias high-end
GT X 1080 the RX 570 has also received a
frequency bump over the RX 470
it's 12 44 megahertz boost speed makes
it 3% faster than its predecessor in
addition it's more power-hungry than the
Oryx 480 and carries 850 watt TDP which
is the same as the RX 4 80
AMD usually sends reference boards for
reviews but this time around the company
sent us an RX 580 from sapphire in an RX
570 from a sous the sapphire nitro
Radeon rx 580 limited edition card that
we received is overclocked but at $275
it's also 46 dollars more expensive than
the cards based price
sapphires limited edition variant comes
with 8 gigabytes of video RAM and
supports 2 fans in a gunmetal finish the
GPU is overclocked by a hundred 10
megahertz going from a boost speed of 13
40 megahertz to 1450 in terms of power
the card requires a 500 watt or greater
PSU that has an 8 pin and 6 pin power
connector the asou Strix rx 570 is also
overclocked
and at $189 it retails for $20 more than
the GPUs based model the Strix card
supports two fans and offers a modest 34
megahertz overclock over stock models
both cards support features like VR free
sync HDR and 4k streaming in terms of
performance I suggest you read my
in-depth written review for the full
breakdown but the gist of it when it
comes to 1080p gaming is that the RX 580
and 570 make excellent cards aside from
the graphically demanding games like
Metro last light it will max out most
games with higher than 60 average frame
rates this also makes them great GPUs
for high refresh rate panels at 1440p
the RX 580 and 570 will be able to run
most games like shadow of Mordor and
Unreal Engine titles like BioShock
Infinite with playable frame rates you
will most likely want to turn some
settings down in the more graphically
demanding games however 4k is the
resolution that really separates the
wheat from the chaff the rx 580 and 570
may be able to muster over 30 average
fps in many moderately Texan games at 4k
but they scored the line so closely that
you're better off running the game at
lower resolutions to get smoother more
consistent gameplay really graphically
demanding games like last light will
crush the card to 2160p while the gtx
1060 and rx 580 generally trade
performance blows in VR the gtx 1060
seems the best the RX 580 by 11%
according to valve steamvr benchmark the
RX 585 70 and 480 are all v are capable
cards and come within spitting distance
of each other if you want top-tier GPU
performance from AMD that rivals and
videos 'best offerings you have to wait
for AMD to release its Vega GPUs later
this year what we have here are budget
oriented cards that punch a bit above
their price sapphire slightly
overclocked rx 580 trades blows with
Nvidia slightly more expensive gtx 1060
going to our benchmark data it's really
too close to declare a definitive winner
one downside to the rx 580 is that it
consumes a lot of power for a mid-range
card when you take the average of our
performance benchmarks sapphires rx 580
is roughly 16% bastard then as Souza's
rx 570 the latter of which performs
neck-and-neck with
AMD's reference for 80 before it neither
the 580 or 570 offer huge performance
jumps over their respective predecessors
they're still compelling GPUs for those
who want to gain at 1080p and 1440p and
don't want to break the bank getting
there
which video card are you planning to
upgrade to let us know in the comments
below
if you like this video give it a thumbs
up and subscribe to us on YouTube